[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de hoy a
nuestra mesa de trabajo rosa feliz
mañana de martes entonces abrimos esta
revista de prensa con una exclusiva de
el medio the gardian que entrevistó al
informante que filtró los 124 mil
documentos utilizados como los papeles
de uber los super papers buenos días
raúl exactamente no ayer dedicamos a
todo este espacio a abordar ciertos
puntos de esta información como bien
dices los papeles de uber que señalaban
las malas prácticas la expansión tan
agresiva violando legislaciones
utilizando la violencia entre el sector
del taxi y el über para poder expandirse
alrededor del mundo y recordemos como
ayer bien comentamos esta investigación
nació de una filtración como decías de
124 mil documentos de los cuales 83 mil
eran mensajes internos de uber que
fueron filtrados at the gardian que the
gardian a pasó al consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación que repartió entre
distintos medios y que finalmente fue
publicado el domingo pero como bien
decías
ahora the gardian publica la entrevista
exclusiva con el informante como tal no
quien decidió sacar a la luz todas estas
malas prácticas por un lado la vemos en
la portada en papel de estacada esta
entrevista con la cita siguiente dice
decidí hablar para corregir algunos
errores fundamentales y señala que tiene
cierto remordimiento no el informante de
uber estoy exponiendo un sistema que
vendió una mentira a la gente vamos al
perfil del informante como tal se llama
marc mcgann tiene 52 años y en
particular fue uno de los principales
lobbistas es decir las gentes las
personas que se dedican a presionar a
los gobiernos digamos para favorecer una
legislación que beneficia a sus empresas
también a presionar a medios de
comunicación a hacer campañas favorables
etcétera marc mcgann fue el lobbista
encargado de la expansión de uber en
áfrica medio oriente y europa y por qué
decide hablar ahora bien por un lado
como decíamos para corregir a ciertos
errores tiene dice cierto remordimiento
porque participó en el hecho de que über
a sabiendas leyes en decenas de países y
engañar a las personas sobre los
beneficios para los conductores de su
modelo de negocio como bien hablábamos
ayer hubiera participado de esta misma
verificación de la economía como su
propio nombre indica y una una cita que
tiene este texto dice soy en parte
responsable yo era quien hablaba con los
gobiernos yo era el que presionaba los
medios y ahora el que decía a la gente
que tenían que cambiar las normas para
que los conductores se pudieran
beneficiar y los clientes pudieran
acceder a opciones más económicas y dice
ahora fue una mentira así es ross además
es una de las personas claves en toda
esta trama en los papeles de google
efectivamente y esta es una digamos de
las cosas que señala the gardian porque
como ayer bien comentábamos en la página
web del consorcio internacional de
periodistas de investigación donde
tenemos distintas pestañas que muestran
puntos clave de esta investigación uno
de digamos de las páginas que podemos
observar esa gráfica da así no en una
pantalla de celular digamos haciendo
referencia a la aplicación dv vemos las
personas claves que participaron en esta
en esta trama desde líderes
internacionales a lobbistas digamos a
burócratas y vemos básicamente aquí de
lo visto marc mcgann y es el hombre el
informante al que hacemos referencia y
bien como bien decías the gardian señala
que es inhabitual que una persona
implicada de forma tan activa y a tan
alto nivel
denuncie la trama en la que digamos
estaba implicada no por un por otro lado
queríamos a señalar la cita que esta
investigación decide extraer de un
mensaje enviado por marx mcgann dice nos
permitimos la traducción literal
básicamente uber irrumpe y luego hay una
tormenta de legal y regulatoria
en referencia pues como über se ha
expandido digamos a violando las leyes
de licencia de los taxistas la cuestión
del estatuto falsos autónomos la
comisión a que se lleva uber sin aportar
digamos condiciones laborales dignas
etcétera también vemos aquí digamos la
cita de travis calanni que el que era
así o de über en ese momento que dice la
violencia garantiza el éxito y aquí
quizás está la clave de otro de los
motivos que ha hecho hablar a este
hombre y es que él fue una de las
figuras no que digamos salió a la luz
con la expansión de uber en europa y fue
atacado e incluso ha amenazado digamos y
por eso dice tiene ciertos daños
psicológicos y un poco reprocha a ver
puedes hacer causante de estos y haberlo
puesto en una situación tan delicada
también veíamos a macro no no como
personas clave en esta trama como bien
comentamos allá así es rosa usted se
comportaría de manera diferente si la
estuvieran grabando todo el tiempo pues
no lo será un en todo caso es obvio que
la policía de sao paulo sí sí claro que
sí porque desde que estos policías
tienen en su cuerpo las cámaras
corporales para grabar todos los
operativos policiales las muertes
entonces a manos de ellos han reducido
un 80 por ciento no rosa este ha sido el
caso de las 19 unidades de policía
militar de sao paulo a las que se las da
instalado cámaras corporales que les
vigilan en todo momento durante todas
las operaciones como vemos en este
gráfico que señala las muertes por año
como entidades por la policía militar de
estas 19 unidades no que veíamos como de
329 o 207 en los últimos dos años pasó a
41 en este último año del que se tiene
registro esto no significa que sea de
las muertes cometidas por toda la
policía militar de sao paulo sino
solamente de las 19 de las a las que se
ha instalado cámaras en los uniformes
rosa muy muy rápidamente tenemos
imágenes del telescopio james webb
exactamente y queríamos destacar como
cuatro medios asia que del continente
americano lo llevan en sus portadas el
'washington post' diciendo una mirada
profunda hacia el espacio y el tiempo lo
más cerca de ver galaxias que se
formaron poco después del big bang que
hemos estado también vemos el wall
street journal la nasa muestra las
primeras imágenes de los lugares más
profundos del espacio que hemos podido
alcanzar el comercio de perú primera
imagen del espacio tomada por el
telescopio webb o la nación de argentina
que lo titula como esto rosa gracias
como siempre por toda la información
mañana con más saludamos a nuestro
primer invitado del día